tonight here to discuss her new book
sneaking into the Flying Circus is
journalist filmmaker alexandra pelosi
where she reveals as the subtitle states
how the media turned our presidential
campaigns into freak shows now before I
introduce alexandra i would like to say
that over there is a microphone and
since this is being taped by c-span if
you have any questions please go to that
microphone and ask them and have that
having been said alexandra pelosi hello
thank you all very much for coming i see
some very familiar faces in the audience
my sister Christine is here who has
taught me so much about what happens in
this strange little town of yours so I'd
like to welcome my sister Christine
Christine makes a few cameos in the book
when she breaks it all down for me
congresswoman Anna su thank you so much
for being here and what seeing you here
and Marti Russo you both will understand
seeing you here reminds me of how
difficult it is to be on this side of
the microphone you know I'm a journalist
and I work in dark edit rooms and so
it's hard I think for people to stand in
front of a microphone because you have
to be very careful of what you say
especially with our friends from c-span
here you don't want to offend anybody
and you know that's I think what's wrong
with politics now is that it's so
polarized and that every word you say is
used like a bomb against you so I thank
you for being here and I think that I
have a new appreciation for you standing
here and I'd like to just make one point
in the back of the room I see someone
from the Gephardt campaign Eric Smith is
here and I see Terry Learman from the
Dean campaign I think it's really nice
that I could be the one to bring you
back together after all
I don't want to bore you with my story
I'd much rather find out from you what
you want to talk about here today I'm
not gonna read from the book because I
think that it's more interesting for you
to ask me questions to find out what you
want to know about I will just give you
some setup in case you just walked in
off the street and don't know who I am
or what I'm doing here I was a
journalist with NBC News for many years
I spent the 20s slaving away in the
sweatshops at Rockefeller Center as a
producer and then I got a call one day
do you have any pets
no why well because we need someone to
go to Austin Texas to cover the bush
campaign that was my qualification I was
single and had no pets so I moved to
Austin Texas and I sat on a bus for a
year and a half with very little sleep
eating many turkey sandwiches and
bathing rarely this is the life of a
traveling journalist and then when I got
back I made a movie about my experiences
called journeys with George and that was
in 2002 then in 2004 HBO sent me out to
make another movie and it was about how
to run for president I went with the
Democrats to find out what it takes to
run for president so I asked all of the
candidates you know what are you
learning here on your road trip that you
didn't know before you got into this
game and so that's what the book is the
book is sort of a diary of all of these
interviews and conversations I had with
the candidates along the way to explain
to them it's them explaining what
they're learning on the campaign trail
but more importantly the reason I felt
the need to write the book in the first
place was because as a journalist on the
campaign trail I felt that the
relationship between the press and the
candidate was very complicated and it's
something that you never get to hear
about when you're watching c-span and
it's you know traveling with a
presidential candidate is it's a very
elite fraternity and a select few get
this kind of access it's a very
expensive venture HBO had to pay around
ten
to $20,000 a week to keep me on the road
it's phenomenal
so you understand it's a it's a very
close-knit community of working
journalists and like any other
complicated little ecosystem it along
the way sort of their rules of
engagement and their there's all sorts
of you know just like a fraternity
there's sort of hazing rituals and all
sorts of experiences that you share that
you don't really get to read about when
you're reading the paper and the thing
that I came away from the campaign's
feeling was that you know when you're
reading the newspaper it's just one
person's experience and you're one
person and there's certain things that
you want to know but there's no way that
that person is gonna write about the
things that you want to know about if
you're sitting there you would have a
completely different experience and so
this is just my experience I saw things
differently I thought I think everybody
in this room sees things differently but
I saw things differently and so I wanted
to share what I saw all the things that
you don't get to see on the evening
there's all the things you don't really
get to hear and from the candidates
mouths but it's not really supposed to
be you know about policies per se it's
about the experience of running for
president in the modern day and age so
with that I would like to take questions
because I think that would be the most
constructive use of your time here so if
anybody would like to ask a question
feel free otherwise they'll just keep
rambling cuz you know I could go all
night
anybody feel comfortable come on let's
see yes okay favorites we have to play
the favorites game I really enjoyed
congressman get part Senator Joe
Lieberman and Senator Graham because
they were the most honest with me when I
would ask them question about okay so
here you are running for president
what's the hardest part and one would
say you read things about yourself from
the paper each day that just aren't true
and you just have to live with that
otherwise if you start complaining then
you sound like a crazy person so you
have to have really thick skin you know
you know this year but you know most
people don't realize how what you'd in
the paper is so different from the
actual what's actually going on anyone
that's close to something knows it's
totally different when you're up close
than it is to the outside world so I
liked the candidates that were honest
with me and I think that the there's
something really dangerous I think
that's happening in the elections and I
think it's only getting worse which is I
think that with the proliferation of
these small handycams like I use you
have all of these young kids running
around sticking camcorders in the
candidates face like I do and it makes
the candidates so weary that you're
eliminating their ability to be honest
with you because they know anything they
say to you can and will be used against
them so it's complicated and I felt like
when I met the candidates like Joe
Lieberman I saw him on TV and I thought
he was so boring and I thought he he
never was an attractive candidate but in
real life he was really a great guy mr.
personality but you never saw that on TV
so there's a way that the television
filters things which i think is
interesting because every candidate was
different in person than they were on
television because television filters
everything obviously everybody knows
that but but I think you know it's our
democracy and it's it's our country and
we all have a role in this and but most
people don't really have any idea about
who these people really are and what
they really stand for and I don't think
that the media really serves the
American public I I call it a circus
because traveling on a presidential
campaign you really do feel like you're
with Barnum & Bailey you are on a bus
it's more like being with a
rock-and-roll band you go town to town
and the candidate comes out and he
delivers a stump speech and then you
pack up the bus and you roll off to the
next town and it really is a charade in
a weird way it's all made for the
television camera and you never really
do get a sense that it's about anything
more than just being a show no it's all
just a show and
and you can't really blame the
journalists in a way because they're
captives they really are being held
hostage by the campaign's and you can't
blame the campaign's because they're
just trying to do their job to protect
the candidate so we when I spend time as
a journalist I really see it from the
journalists perspective I really start
to see I'm tired of these campaign
people lying to me all the time
it's not lying it's just withholding
information right I'm tired of them
withholding information and not telling
me what I want to know but when I'm
around anybody who is in public life
like congresswoman su I get a real
appreciation because I've seen so many
times where I was standing there when
something was said in front of a
reporter and then read it in the paper
and thought that wasn't really it's so
out of context when it appears in print
that so it's a complicated game and it's
getting just I think it's only just
getting worse I was sitting on it I was
on the TV show a couple weeks ago with
Carl Bernstein and I told him my theory
that Watergate was the worst thing that
ever happened to American politics and
American journalism because essentially
it made all politicians weary of the
press at the same time it made all these
young aspiring press people like me
think I want to be a journalist I want
to be like Dustin Hoffman and and get
the story but we're lazy and we don't
want to do the legwork to get a storm
that story took years to get and I think
in this day and age and the in the cable
news instant gratification world that
we're living in it's a lot harder to get
the story in and the news networks the
news outlets don't really devote that
kind of time and energy to letting you
work for a year on a story I just don't
think it happens I think it's more just
scandal of the day now anyway so
Colburn's needed me on that point I just
want you to know that I'm not totally
talking out of my rear end
the media point of view of how to behave
on the campaign trail I had I learned a
lot on the campaign trail on both sides
and I think that one of the lessons and
this sounds really depressing it's not
supposed to I think a candidate really
needs to say very little I mean I'm not
giving this a prescription I don't work
for Candace I wouldn't tell them this
but I think the rules are becoming that
you have to save very little because my
experience on the campaign trail was the
two candidates that said the least went
the farthest I mean John Kerry and John
Edwards were great candidates because
they stuck to the script they were on
message they delivered a show and then
they loaded up the bus and moved on to
the next town look Howard Dean is an
example of someone who really decided to
share all of his opinions on every
subject with everyone and I think it
really undermined his campaign in the
end I think he just sort of provoked the
media you know and it sort of it was a
great story in the end right and so okay
questions any other questions don't be
shy I have to get up here and stand here
if we had all been flies on the bus
walls do you think the outcome would
have been different
Wow I think that's a great question I
really like that question because I
think that the nominee what I don't
think we would have had the nominee that
we had and on the Democratic side
because I think that the media had too
strong of a role in building up Howard
Dean and then destroying him and then
shoving Kerry into the spot me why was
Kerry the nominee because Dean fell and
there was no one else there the
candidates like congressman Dick
Gephardt who spent his 30 years serving
America no one ever heard of him because
the media some of the anointed newsmen
in their networks just decided Dick
Gephardt wasn't gonna make it into the
final round of the horse race and so I
feel that we would have given other
candidates more of consideration I think
Bob Graham certainly served this country
with distinction for many years and he
was completely ignored by the media Joe
Lieberman I would say the same but his
politics may not have worked in a
primary but I do think that some of the
candidates really didn't get a fair shot
and that's sort of just
Durr Bing to me at least I hope it is to
you to maybe you have a if you have a
opposing view feel free to share it it's
a discussion here yes some would say
that the blogs actually give candidates
that don't get a fair shake by the
traditional media a chance do you agree
with that and do you think that bloggers
are journalists
I guess would be a question oh I love
the plugs because I think it's the only
sign that there's gonna be any change in
this country because right now you just
have these old networks they're
dinosaurs they're dying we've been
saying this for years but they just
they're becoming extinct and the only
way that you can change the next
election each one of you sitting here is
to go to an event yourself and see it
with your own two eyes and then write
your own personal account and share it
share it with your friends put even if
your blog is just your own your sister
and your boyfriend reading it doesn't
matter you can share you on experience
you know I interviewed lots of people at
events that had such a bad experience
going to see a candidate I don't want to
target you know isolate one candidate to
embarrass him but I was at a John
Edwards rally in New York and the
students there were so disillusioned
that came they loved John Edwards they
came and they found when they got there
that they were told to stand and hold a
wave a flag and they were being used as
props and they were so disillusioned and
when I interviewed them afterwards I
realized that most people walk into the
system very positive and then they go
participate in event and they see it
completely differently so I think if you
get up off your couch and you go to an
event yourself and share your
experiences with people you know it will
affect the political climate and that's
the only way we're gonna change this
country don't you think come on somebody
tuck back any other questions yes sir oh
one of your leading questions during the
making of the movie was what does it
take to become president during the
campaign's have you found that answer
what does it take to become president
and if so if you fathered answer what
does that mean for the 2008 campaign
does it go for that campaign as well or
has time already gone so fast that's a
whole different book well in my book
sneaking into the Flying Circus I feel
like I'm on an infomercial how the media
turn our president
campaigns and freak shows there is a
guide there is a after each of the
candidates dropped out I did a
post-mortem interview with each of them
and I asked them for their opinions and
it was the first time that they were all
completely candid I mean they were
always careful during the election but
after you lose you can let it all hang
out and I learned a lot from that now I
didn't know you were gonna ask that
question so I didn't hear mark the page
but you know there is a list of the top
ten things that I learned let me just
flip for a moment and then if you if the
next gentleman would like to ask his
question I can try and find it yes go
ahead
you want you started the campaign I'm
sure with with feelings about the
candidates were they bolstered by what
you saw how did you change your mind
some of the candidates completely
undermined my reality Joe Lieberman for
example when I saw him I thought I have
to spend a week with Joe Lieberman that
was what I thought the first day I went
to a New Year's Day party at Joe
Lieberman's house and I thought this is
the year I'm gonna have but he ended up
being so he ended up telling me stories
about how he got his name out there and
got started in this business and he he
told me a lot of the secrets of the
trade which are all in the book and I
really learned a lot about you know he'd
been through a national campaign so he
taught me little things you would never
know but like this I never knew I was
gonna have to spend a year eating off of
my lap you know you think of these men
from the United States Senate as being
distinguished gentlemen and they have to
ride around in RVs eating off of their
lap you know it's a nice image I think
and so I had ideas about each of them
and some of them turned out to be
exactly what I thought they lived up to
the caricature and others surprised but
all of them deserve so much credit for I
mean I don't want to say anything bad
about him because to think about what it
takes to have to stand up in front of a
crowd and do what they do every day I
have so much appreciation for what they
do okay so let's go back to
your question about the lessons that I
learned I wasn't planning to read and
I'm not a very good reader but if do we
have any volunteers from the audience if
anyone wants to read the top ten lesson
lessons okay number one okay you never
want to be the front-runner it gives the
media the license to pick apart your
personal psychology and break down every
word that comes out of your mouth
eventually they will lose interest in
you and go looking for a new story
lesson number two timing is everything
you have to pace yourself
the burnout factor is high and he who
gets the most sleep wins as the French
say the Tour de France is won in bed
number three define yourself before the
media defines you you need to
differentiate yourself but don't try to
sell your experience because no one's
buying it you need to have a good story
everybody's looking for a Seabiscuit
number four you need money
it'd be good if you could mortgage your
own home number five you need a good
team okay
Taryn Lerman Eric Smith this is you you
need a good team the first question you
should ask yourself is where am I gonna
get the staff the execution is the
hardest part a lot of the candidates
thought I have all this experience I
know all the issues this is gonna be
easy and then they got out there and
they realized it's really hard you have
to change gears so quickly if to raise
the money and then you have to go to the
hog Lots and play with the Hogs and then
you have to go to a top dollar
fundraiser
it's the switching gears it's very
difficult you have to be shameless I
like this one you have to do a lot of
begging and it's not glamorous
it's like competing in a beauty contest
but you never feel pretty especially
when you're eating off your lap well I
guess we know where that one came from
you have to look you have to have the
look Kari looked the most presidential
you have to be able to perform on TV it
was a victory for the guy who knew how
to use the camera you have to be egoless
people like it when you say things like
I don't care about being president take
your ego out of it and act like a
populist you have to not need it this is
important if any of you are gonna run
for president you should be taking notes
right now
nobody likes desperation they can smell
it a mile away
you have to be able to switch gears
instantly that was the one I was just
explaining to you because I really
thought that one and number 10 oh the D
niak in the back of the room will know
where this quote came from you've got a
half skin thicker than steel
people say terrible things about you
every day most of which are not true
which makes running for president with
Thomas Jefferson called splendid misery
so those are just a few of the ideas of
what the candidates said along the way
and the PS which none of them would
admit was you have to be nice all of the
time which I would find so painful I
mean can you imagine just the perma-grin
just smiling all the time especially the
people like me with cameras in their
face oh I think that would be awful okay
any other questions come on oh yes
please
I was hoping we would be having a
conversation here this doesn't have to
be a monologue
actually I have two questions I'm a
German journalist I covered a campaign
for a German daily national daily so the
first question would be why carry I was
so surprised when I met him and dad
mouth and some other places there was a
depressed looking guy looking at me and
not looking at me at the same time and
stumbling into speeches so why carrying
the second thing as I would like to
follow on the lowest fare thing I
foresee in 2008 people had you and me
constantly watching my little PDA and
sifting through all these blogs there
anything coming up a new girlfriend
something like that there's wasn't a
campaign the ad Ward's name on the plane
it came out all out of the blogs but I
was myself finding sitting in front of
my laptop instead of going out to the
candidates and I did not check their
issues I did constantly check the
scanners popping up so will that
multiply by a hundred in 2008 that's a
very good question I don't know just
because I'm standing here doesn't mean I
know anything I'm just telling you about
my experience and I spent four camp I
mean four years on the first campaign
four years anyway you get my point
I only had one experience and that was
covering George Bush in 2000 covering
the down
in 2004 I don't know what's gonna happen
in 2008 and I don't know what the future
is but I guess we we can all guess right
but I would say why carry I think anyone
in the room knows the answer to this
question which was he you know Dean was
self-destructing and Kerry was able to
mortgage his house and sell himself as
the war hero people really dug that
whole war hero thing but those of us
covering the campaign knew all along it
was his Achilles heel and that the Swift
Boat vets were out there in Iowa they
were out there in New Hampshire they
were coming we smelt them I mean they
would come up and try and grab any
microphone they could get their hands on
you remember that if you were a
journalist in Iowa or New Hampshire so
we knew they were coming the only
question was what are they going to do
when they get there you know what was
the Kerry campaign gonna do to respond
when the Swift boats come and they had a
year to prepare but so I think that
obviously you know with with Douglas
Brinkley's book promoting Kerry as this
war hero and saying this is who I am I'm
gonna define myself you know I think
that ended up being a fatal flaw but we
all have our own opinions about that and
I'm not really an expert so I'll take
the next question just to choose the
subject um you said Dean self-destruct
but from everything I read about it it
was really the media that didn't explain
what happened that they filtered out the
audience so that his screams came over
and so to me the media destructed him of
course they did I think that any one
with a conscience working in the media
would admit that they gratuitously
exploited this scream but the reason
they did that is because when you're
covering a campaign it's so boring every
single day and that you need some action
and this was the first piece of action
they had seen remember his press corps
he had three dean had three busloads of
press in iowa going to these tiny little
towns and most of the events were pool
only and not to talk you know the lingo
but that just means that one person goes
in for the whole press corps so people
were sitting on buses all day with no
action imagine sitting on a bus for 12
hours with nothing to write in your
newspaper so you start to get resentful
and it's one of the lessons we learned
from Dean is you know you have to seduce
and charm the press if you're running
for president that's just a reality
you're gonna have to deal with them and
Dean refused to do that he admitted
openly I'm not gonna charm and seduce
those people I'm running on principles
I'm not trying to you know win a beauty
pageant here so he went with his
principles and it backfired because the
press got really tired of sitting on the
bus without anything to write and then
it just happened it was like the moment
everyone was starting to write these
stories complaining that they were
sitting on a bus for 12 hours I know
this sounds very petty to you because
you're sitting here and we're talking
about democracy but you have to remember
this is the context the next time you
read the paper you'll remember this
because you're talking about a you know
a pack of what West Clark jr. calls semi
drunk nerds sitting on a bus that have
nothing to do all day and so this
happens and day go for it now I want to
explain one thing I know
join I I I feel your pain I felt it for
a long time but I want to say this I
want to just explain that sort of the
context of the book there were three
characters that really inspired me to
actually write a book I know it's like
overwhelming like you find a book but
there are three people that really made
me think I have to do this one was Candy
Crowley from CNN because she covers the
news every single day and she said this
is getting out of control you know what
we do were turning these candidates and
to caricatures and they're just becoming
so scripted and it's getting so hard to
see anything real and it's it's really
hard to do my job in the environment
that we're living in now that was one
the second was Howard Dean because after
he lost he was so upfront about the
problems that our media has right now
the American media right now is really
in trouble
I mean maybe Dean had a really a
personal experience there that didn't go
so well but all of his points are
legitimate what they did to him was
really unbelievable okay and the third
person was Wes Clark jr. because he was
the one
I could really relate to this he used to
be really close to his father on the
campaign trail and he would be there
watching his father perform for the
media and then he wouldn't pick up the
paper the next day he would say half the
things here are not true he would fact
check articles and say this isn't true
this isn't true this isn't sure this in
true now he saw it from both sides right
he could see the way it was written and
could see having a relationship with his
father how it played so talking to him I
realized something is going wrong I mean
all three Candy Crowley Howard Dean and
Wes Clark jr. were the three voices that
I used in the book but you know I think
that my point about American journalism
going downhill since Watergate the
voices in the book really tell us how
I'm trying to be very delicate with what
I say with a camera rolling I'm not
gonna be screaming like Howard Dean the
American media is in trouble and when it
comes to covering presidential elections
we've been covering them the since the
dawn of time the same way pack of
half-drunk nerds sitting on the bus and
we have to do something to improve that
I think I think you'd all agree well I
think the idea of you know young people
going out and having their own
experience and writing about it on their
blogs and sharing it with their friends
and people realizing that the media are
not anointed to be the deliverers of
truth and information they're just
that's one person's perspective sitting
on the bus every time you read the paper
just think this is one person's
perspective and what I'm reading is the
quotes from the one person who called
them back with the recent passing of
Hunter s Thompson I'd be interested in
your thoughts on your work in the
context of his trailblazing work on the
campaign trail and what that holds for
the future what you know our blogs and
you know what's what's the future of
this sort of what's going to shake up
the campaign trail in journalistically I
think people leaving their homes and
going to the events and reporting it
back to their friends I think it's the
only way everyone is in unrest Tom I
mean everybody can tell their own
version of the story
you know I talked to seven women at Anne
Edwards event who are all very
disillusioned
the political process and I learned more
from those seven college students than
anything I'd learn on the campaign trail
I mean all you have to do is go to an
event and you'll see it for yourself so
I would encourage everybody and maybe
you're all very politically active but
this book was not written for the inside
the beltway politically active person it
was written for all the high school and
college students that email me and ask
me all these kinds of questions I get
flooded with questions from people that
have seen my movies and they ask
questions like why did the media exploit
Howard Dean scream like that how am I
supposed to answer that
I just asked reporters those questions
and tried to um
I see another familiar face from the
campaign trail MATLAB ash from the
Weekly Standard back there okay okay
he's hiding but we know you're here okay
vast right-wing conspiracy back of the
room on the left
thank you I went to a I heard a Kerry's
speech I went to a Dean rally but the
rest of the time I have to listen to the
radio watch TV read the newspapers there
does no alternative I have to rely on
the media there's no there's no fourth
choice well then you should demand that
your media do a better job don't write
them let my fear of reporters who do
have principles oh yeah there are lots
of great journals I mean I told you
Candy Crowley was my hero she's my
inspiration I mean I work in television
and if I could be anyone when I grow up
it would be Candy Crowley from CNN so
there are good examples of people who
practice journalism responsibly it's
like Abu Ghraib they're good apples and
they're bad apples and you never know
which one you're getting that day than
when you're reading the paper I did have
experiences on the Bush campaign where I
would be at an event and then the next
day I would pick up the newspaper and I
would read something and I'd say that is
not how it happened but this reporter
had a different experience than I did he
you know when you're traveling on a
presidential campaign you're in an
airplane and it's like a long narrow
tube
he had conversations
I was not privy to in the front of the
plane I had conversations that he did
not have in the back of the plane so our
experiences were all different based on
where we were assigned on the plane and
I told you there's a caste system
because it is just like high school
there's like the cool kids in the front
and the New York Times the cool kids
because you know all of the candidates
are all intellectual well in this case
it was like a New England thing so they
all like prayed with the New York Times
in the morning like they reviewed every
word that was written about them and
they didn't care about what HBO or you
know other places said about them so um
you know just just be a little more
skeptical when you're reading that's
time a great question I'm from
Massachusetts what happened to the rest
of the country I don't know what do you
guys think happened to the rest of the
country any ideas I'm sure all of you
have your own opinions and I think
that's great and I think you know that's
sort of what we're here to celebrate is
that just because you're on the
employment of the major networks doesn't
mean that you're the only opinion that
matters right is there anything we can
learn from the short elections in
Britain recently held I know it's a
different system but still doesn't it
yet one thing I this is very funny but I
don't know if any of you saw any of Tony
Blair but when Tony Blair was being
grilled they people would say you're a
liar you lied about the war and he'd say
well I understand that you think that
that wasn't the right decision but I
didn't call it a lie so I loved that he
everyone was honest with him and he was
honest back and then if you watched The
Daily Show they edited that next to a
bush town hall meeting and it's like I'm
so glad you're my president so um I
think that we what we learned from from
the British I mean obviously they know
how to do it they do it quickly and they
don't waste two years with this you know
the horse race that we have here but
more importantly I think that the thing
from watching Tony Blair I said he has
some joy and I think that what's missing
with in an answer to your question about
John Kerry Kerry didn't have any joy you
have to have joy and people need to want
to be around you like Tony Blair you
watch me you think I want to listen to
him what does he have to say there's a
joy factor that
you know with cable 24-hour cable news
you have to have some joy so it's a good
lesson for all you potential candidates
out there ratchet up the joy factor
don't walk around with that you know
that what was your description of John
Kerry yeah I will say this about John
Kerry I think he had no idea what there
was a complete disconnect between who he
was and who he thought he was and who
the public thought he was he didn't
really seem to he had a different
opinion of himself most people are a
little more self-aware they can say I
think the public isn't responding to
this or that but he seemed to not really
understand what the public really
thought of him so I thought that that
was sort of interesting does anyone know
what I'm talking about
okay speak up we can hear you come on
all right all right have I been talking
for too long I'm getting that impression
that I've been rambling at this point
and if there's any other yes they
weren't allowed on the Cheney plane is
that right that certain newspapers were
banned and did that happen with other
there were newspapers others in New York
time well like I did read that in the
paper that's the only way I know what
you're talking about I mean I know about
that experience I got kicked off the
carry plane more than once so and I do
remember other journalists who asked
questions they didn't like that suddenly
disappeared so there is you know there
is a situation where you pay to play you
can go along but you have to play by the
rules and if you're not smiling and on
your best behavior and playing the game
they can instantly have no seat for you
in Louisville Kentucky and you can be
left on the tarmac I mean it happens so
you know it is interesting what happens
to the New York Times because it's a
story didn't really make news when it
happen to other people but I guess
that's the power of the paper of record
system where the risk is much more
outrageous things than our
seems to get away with it right well god
bless them the motherland they seem to
be doing something right over there
would anyone like to share their own
opinions I think it would be really nice
if someone shared their own opinion on
the subject on any of this the election
the media the how they're feeling today
will take anything we can get over here
okay yes it was bad before I mean
everybody knew what his opinion was on
Social Security I mean things haven't
changed since November and now his
popularity is going down I to me it's
totally the press's fault that his
popularity wasn't down before November
I'm gonna have to take you on the book
tour with me because you articulated
much better than I do
we're from Massachusetts and politics is
part of my life